[Music]
we have studied how to differentiate a
given function
with respect to an independent variable
for example consider this function f of
x equal to x square
now we can also write this equation as y
equal to x square
where y is the dependent variable and x
is the independent variable now can you
tell me
what will be the differentiation of y
equal to x square
yes it's given by d y by dx
equal to 2x now we will bring all the
terms to the left-hand side
and write the equation like this
the equation that you see here is unlike
any other equations that you've seen so
far
it involves variables as well as
derivative of the dependent variable y
with respect to the independent variable
x
such an equation which contains the
derivatives of the dependent variable
with respect to the independent
variables is called
a differential equation
now there are two basic concepts of
differential equations
that we need to understand namely
order and degree
so let's understand these concepts
consider the given equation y equal to f
of x let's differentiate this equation
with respect to x on doing so
we get d y by dx equal to f dash of
x as the function is differentiated once
the derivative here is called the first
order derivative
if we again differentiate the given
equation with respect to x
we get d square y by dx square
equal to f double dash of x
as the derivative is differentiated
twice
the derivative here is thus called the
second order derivative
now let's define the order of a
differential equation
the order of a differential equation is
defined
as the order of the highest order
derivative of the dependent variable
with respect to the independent variable
involved
in the differential equation
now let's see some examples related to
this concept
consider this differential equation
here this is the highest order
derivative
in the given differential equation
and the order of this derivative is 3
hence the order of this differential
equation is
three now consider this differential
equation
here this is the highest order
derivative in the equation
and the order of this derivative is two
hence the order of this differential
equation
is two and what about this equation
yes here the order of the differential
equation
is one now let's move on to the next
concept degree of a differential
equation
the degree of a differential equation is
the highest power of the highest order
derivative
involved in the given differential
equation
one important point to note is that the
differential equation
must be a polynomial equation in
derivatives
for the degree to be defined
now let's understand this concept of
degree using some examples
here d3y by dx cube
is the highest order derivative and its
power
is one thus the degree of this
differential equation
is one in this case
the power of the highest order
derivative is again 1
thus the degree of the differential
equation is 1.
now can you tell me the degree of this
equation
here the highest order derivative is d y
by dx
and we have two terms of d y by dx
having powers two and one respectively
now according to the definition we have
to consider the highest power of the
highest order derivative
the highest power in this case is two
thus the degree of this equation is also
two
so can you tell me the degree of this
differential equation
if your answer is one then it's wrong
why is it wrong well observe
these three equations here we can write
them in the form of a polynomial
equation in derivatives
like this but this equation is not a
polynomial equation
in derivatives does its degree is not
defined
so with that we've understood what is
order
and degree of a differential equation
now in the next video we will solve some
examples
to understand it even better so see you
in the next video